any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to this
week's episode of the into the
impossible podcast i am your fearful
host brian keating
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
at uc san diego and on this podcast we
talk about
uh very uh numerous ideas and and
opinions we talk about very painful
divorces
uh medication medical elapses and in our
guest history
no we don't we don't actually do that i
don't know
arthur c clarke i didn't know he was so
fascinated by all that
uh so james and i actually met six years
ago
uh this year five and a half years ago
in november of 20
so first of all my guest is james
altucher none other than the famous
james altucher
host of the james altercher show on uh
on the interwebs
and i actually met james uh back in 2014
we
both shared the stage here at uh san
diego's very own tedx
centerpiece and actually it was very
awkward for me james as i was tweeting
to some of my friends today
i felt kind of you know torn at that
moment because
you were the final speaker you were the
lead up to everybody uh on that day so i
was kind of a warm-up act but i was
sandwiched between
you at the very end author of the power
of no
and another author by uh by the name of
william urry
or yuri uh who wrote getting to yes and
i kind of felt like i was back you know
the child of divorced parents and
who was i gonna side with you know james
or or uh or william
and he also had his daughter on and she
had set the record for
you know a plank holding the plank
position longer than i could you know
remain in bed
and this wonderful very inspirational
young lady
uh was on stage demonstrating how to
hold the plank and i still haven't you
know been able to get up to
more than 12 seconds i said a personal
best though
um so i've had uh i've had a deep desire
to get
uh to get james on the podcast he
wouldn't come on he said until i
actually did an interview with an
astronaut while she was on the space
station so i checked that off in january
and then he said uh he wouldn't come on
until he had until i had on uh
you know one of the world's most
successful investors of all time jim
simons
and actually there are connections
between uh james and james simons uh
reputedly called the world's smartest
billionaire
and james simon's jim simons as we call
him he will be our guest
father's day episode so depending on
when you're listening to this uh you can
either go back or forwards in time if
that suits you
and uh actually before i had jim simons
on i asked jim altucher
whether or not uh he had any questions
because it was rumored that he was the
guest that he would most like to have uh
to pick his brains at least when it came
to
investor geniuses and i don't know if
he's ever been on any podcast right no
i think i have the first very secretive
yes he is he's very secretive
there's a very intimate interview very
personal and i can't wait to share it
with the world
uh but so i checked that off the box now
james said he'd come on the show and he
gave me a question to ask
uh dr jim simons and i did ask him that
and after that he's never been on a
podcast but now he's gonna he wants to
start a podcast with you as
the first guest so james altucher
welcome that's a long winded way welcome
to the
to the into the impossible podcast thank
you so much i've been such a huge fan of
yours for
years actually well brian i'm a fan of
yours i mean
everybody should should read your book
uh uh on
almost losing the nobel prize or losing
losing guys
and uh uh you came on my podcast
recently
and it's just such a fascinating
conversation i've been thinking about it
ever since
i kind of want to get a phd in physics
now i've been reading all about einstein
and and you know it's exciting yeah
speaking of that actually i was
listening to a podcast that you must
have recorded it
a couple days on the james altitude show
before you and i got together because
you were going over your tips
for how to run a successful podcast and
actually how you speed read
and you went through this um you went
through an exercise you basically taught
people how to use
uh these tricks and tools that you've
developed i'll put a link to it in the
show notes of this podcast
but one of the podcasts was like uh or
one of the tips for speed reading was
like basically you don't need to know
the whole paragraph that's your thesis
you read the first sentence maybe the
last sentence because nobody really
cares you said
verbatim about you know the boring
details of what happened 13 billion
years ago in the big bang and nobody
really can the author is probably not
that good
because you know he's a non-fiction
writer
[Laughter]
so i thought to myself well that's
really high praise that you were using
me as a cautionary example no no no
here's think about it in terms of like
an academic like
academic research and i it's funny
because i would i just was
doing another podcast with um some
academics and we were talking about are
there too many academic
research articles published per year you
know there's about three million
scientific research articles published
per year and my point there is
if you read the abstract in the summary
you know what the article is about you
don't need to read all the math
that was really my point in that one is
that yeah for me a layman
you know i i was looking at an article
about the
you know dynamic moving blah blah blah
of a
human golf swing and there's all this
math in it i just want to know how to
move a golf
club better so and and my point is most
when i read fiction i try to read every
word because if i'm reading
fiction i'm reading it for to be a
better writer fiction writers
almost by definition are the best
writers they're focused they focus their
careers on writing
other you know if i'm reading um and
i'll i'll even specifically use an
example if i'm reading
well maybe i shouldn't use an example if
i'm reading
uh somebody's history book you know they
wrote and they spent
30 years researching they're experts on
history
they're not experts on writing writing's
a hard skill but
and so is history so i'll i want to know
the history
but they're not going to be the best
writer so sometimes they're going to use
extra words their paragraphs are not
going to be as
formed as well as possible but i will
say
i i almost never ever speed read because
i do think
for to prepare for a podcast it's
important to read
everything it's in some situations and
i've been
managing my schedule better this past
year some situations in prior years i
would have five or six podcast schedules
in a week
i'd have to read just too many books and
like if you happen to seem to leb on
and he's written four books all worth
reading but they're all kind of dense
i'm not i can't read every word no way
so i was really kind of referring to his
actually no it was actually a wonderful
example actually and something that you
might not know just because you're not
in academia
but one of the things that happens most
often is you'll write a paper you'll put
you know a month into a single sentence
and then i'll have a citation and then a
couple weeks after it
gets posted to the what's called the
archive or the uh the you know this
pre-print server we used to call it
it's really like a way to bypass paid
journals and i want to get into that
with you in
in a little bit uh but uh but then
you'll get an email from a crank
you know or a friend you didn't cite my
paper
and uh i feel you know like this is
really relevant and
uh and you don't know this person could
be the referee and this per you know you
have no idea we're gonna get into
gatekeeping
uh choosing not yourself and academia in
a little bit
but one tip that you gave in that
podcast about reading nonfiction was
very pertinent and that's
you know what what the authors love the
most when you read the acknowledgements
when you read
the footnotes and i thought i could do
you one better
uh because i actually think the highest
level of compliment and tell me if you
agree
is when you find a typo in a in a very
well
popular book a book that sold millions
of copies
that's called the power of no and when
you find a typo in that book
uh or maybe even an error is isn't that
the best thing for an author to hear
that a reader has found a typo in his or
her book
hmm that's a difficult question because
on the one hand it does demonstrate
uh an acuity of reading that i i
appreciate and i'm glad that one did but
i don't i don't i don't like to know
that i made any errors so more
it's still probably more interesting to
me to be asked about
who's in the acknowledgements um but
i'll have to try that trick
uh on you know a few future podcast
guests and see what happens
you know by the way for academic papers
though if you find like
you know that's kind of equivalent to
finding like a flaw in the math and i've
done that a couple of times as well
and again the response is sort of mixed
so i i did find a typo in uh the power
of no
which i'll i'll send to you it's uh yeah
i don't know please do
i will i will it's uh page 85
you call isaac you speak about the
importance of leaving your family behind
you talk about the examples in the bible
you know when abraham left his father
and the squabbles of of siblings because
you want to give people the power to
really
be empowered themselves and say no
sometimes means saying no to your family
and you say that isaac and ishmael oh
sorry you say isaac and isaiah
fought with each other but isaiah was
not the brother of isaac so
ishmael i will send that to you yeah
right so isaiah was a prophet
in prophets that's right maybe he had
his own book named after him i forget
yes he did yep yeah so and uh
you're right yeah i don't that's that's
a that's a pretty bad one i don't know
because i'm pretty familiar for whatever
i i'm pretty familiar with the bible and
i and and
i i like these structures i want to get
to that because yeah you use it as an
example or i mean i always say i'd kill
for one percent of god's book sales you
know that would be great
something that had to appeal to people
say 3 000 years ago even nobody
disputes that academic scholars that
it's historically ancient
uh and it still if you look at both the
old testament in the new testament
it's kind of interesting how many people
abandoned
their their fathers yeah like you know
it's called fathers
even in the new testament uh you know
jesus says to
i believe peter you know peter is like
burying his
his father and jesus says let the dead
bury the dead
follow me and so it's it's kind of
a weird thing and we know now that
there's you know of course there's
multiple authors of the new testament we
also know now there's multiple authors
of the old testament
it's just odd this was like a common
theme but it happens to
abraham isaac jacob joseph
uh yeah uh yeah so joseph uh uh
was sort of he was sort of he didn't
abandon jacob but he was kind of kicked
out
and well he does have a chance you know
he's the second i don't want to get too
nerdy on the bible but he
he becomes basically the second in
command to pharaoh for 17 years he
doesn't contact his father to say i'm
alive
uh he waits until his brothers happen by
happenstance come to
egypt but right yeah i want i do want to
talk about your connection to judaism
and
you mention it a lot and as a practicing
but not orthodox
i never want to like burden other
orthodox jews with the sentiment that
i'm an orthodox jew
oh and i'm not even i'm not even
practicing i mean i've practiced my
entire life
yeah yeah so i do want to talk about
that and israel and you know
some other uh very light topics i'm sure
but we'll do that at the end
for now i wanted to get started you know
kick things off with uh
going back to that night in november of
2014.
we shared the stage at tedx san diego
which is really something i look forward
forward to
doing you know since they came up with
the concept of ted of ted talks
um but you really you know kind of set
the stage on fire with
your characteristic vulnera it was right
after choose yourself had come out you
know
a year or so afterwards power of no had
come out and uh and i saw you
and uh and your then uh wife claudia i
believe
uh you guys were in the green room we
hung out and i was like yeah i'll see
you after the show and then
you ghosted me james i haven't seen this
the first time face to face
uh that we've been so what what is your
story about that what do you recall
about that night and
yeah would you do it again i i would
because i think i'm
i think i'm a much different public
speaker than i was
then but i was that was a big
tedx that's like one of the big tedxes
and there was i don't know it was like
i felt like maybe there was 500 or a
thousand or more people there i have no
idea how many people are there's 1500
people
1500 i was so unbelievably terrified
like i have never been that terrified
before a talk like i had been giving
talks probably at that point for about
10 years
and i was really scared and then
right before me was actually the
right before me was gabriel gabrielle
yuri william murray's daughter who was
doing the plank
and you know what was so uh interesting
and vulnerable
and brave about her she has this uh
i don't know what you call like a
chronic illness or an illness since
birth
and so that it was part of the thing
that was amazing about her doing such a
long plank was also her physical issues
and and then right after me and then i
was gonna go on after her and then right
after me was going to be like the san
francisco ballet
and i figured what is going on here like
the audience is going to be crying after
gabrielle
and then they're going to be anxiously
waiting for the ballet like they don't
they're not
i had it in my head the last person they
want to see
is me after gabrielle they just want to
get straight to the ballet it's the end
of a long day
you have this totally emotional
beautiful performance by
gabrielle uri and then you have this
amazing thing with the san diego
ballet it's gonna happen so i left the
conference
and i was not gonna come back and this
was like
this might have been while you were
talking actually and i'm like
walking around the block and i'm
thinking what am i gonna do i can't
i'm just horrified but i did go back i
was terrified
and i went on the stage and this often
happens with publix people should know
who are thinking of being public
speakers this often happens you're
nervous beforehand
but then something some neurochemical
action kicks in when you actually get on
the stage
you something kicks in and you're a new
person again and you and you do your
thing and hopefully you do it well
so so i survived but i really was that
was probably the
moment i've been most terrified to do
public speaking
and i think i did okay like right now if
i were to rate it from a zero to ten i
probably did like a five
but uh it was it was scary so then
afterwards uh just my mind
had burnt me out and i i don't even know
if i watched the ballet i think i was
just
no i don't i don't think so and then we
had this after party which is really fun
because all these
uh you know famous classical guitarists
and and thinkers and
and and me and other people were there
and i remember yeah i was the same way
i've never spoken in front of that many
people live i mean people have seen a
lot of my videos but
but never that many people live and my
mother-in-law
allison was in the audience and she was
like are you nervous and i said
you know i like to pull her legs no not
until just now
how could you ask me such a thing now
when i think about it yes i'm very
terrified why would you ever expect
that she was freaking out because she
made me feel like she thought she made
me feel nervous but
i was a little nervous until we got i
mean we had speaker coaches and of
course they give you alcohol which i
don't
really think about as a positive
influence on towards a good and they
also
you went on last and i think your advice
lately which i which i really agree with
and i commend you on
as well is like if you're going to go on
a comment and i hope we can get to like
the physics of comedy later on
but um but you talk about you had this
opportunity to get out like before bill
burr
or after bill burr and what of course is
the
you don't want to be you know come on
after he's gonna you're gonna get
slaughtered
but you did that for tedx and i wonder
if that was your first kind of endeavor
you know closing out a show basically
closing out a show because the ballet
dancers
uh didn't have much to say uh you know
to the audience they were performing
you know i think it was more the kind of
status of tedx that was scaring me
even more than the size of the audience
like because i've spoken in front of
thousands of people before that but it
was where i was like
more in control of the situation it was
like an event maybe
like i used to be a spokesperson for
fidelity so they would have these huge
events with like
five to ten thousand people and i would
speak
and so i felt a little more comfortable
at those because they were there to see
me
whereas 10x is like just a long day and
everybody's great like look you're
you should be your nobel prize winner
and you were speaking and then there's
me
so you know and then and william yuri
gabriel yuri there's so many great
speakers that were there
and i think i was just and then and then
like you said we were coached
and it was almost like we're over
coached like like my coach
i think didn't really like me that much
and so she's like no do this do this
and like i had already been doing public
speaking for 10 years but i felt like i
had to
stay within the rules of her coaching
because it's
it is tedx and i don't know i i kind of
lost my
my center of psychological gravity
and and again you do kind of get it back
at the end
there's there's other techniques too
there's there's um there's a cognitive
bias if you go last
where it's called uh choice ambiguity
bias so if you say
if the first thing you say is hey
everybody give it uh you know
i'm the last speaker give it up for
everybody who's gone before me so they
all clap
but because you've kind of lumped
everybody into this category
of everybody they actually at that
moment
it's a cognitive they have a hard time
remembering anything
about who they saw before because they
just kind of clap for the group so in
their brain they had to reorganize their
brain to do that clapping what am i not
going to clap for the girl who's got a
congenital disease
right yeah well they probably remember
her but then they but they probably
everyone else becomes the other
right and uh so that's a technique i
often use when i'm on last it usually
works
but this time i was just yeah i was just
in in a state of tariff you know and
then and then afterwards
it i was you know whatever we had 15
minutes
i was just totally burnt out you know
what's funny
now looking back at my talk because i
watched videos of my
talks just to study them and even now
i'll watch talks from
2013 2014. i've watched that talk
recently and
i can see now what i've learned since
then and
and i think i would do things
differently now
the key would be though would be to
overcome the coaching because
ultimately now in retrospect i don't
think the coaching was was that great
but uh and not to criticize her she
might have been doing what they told her
to do
but i think i would have played it a
little differently if i if i was the
coach
yeah i want to get your thoughts on the
rapid fire you know portion
that's uh the the blitz at the end of
the conversation about you know is ted
over as or are we past peak ted
uh but we'll get to that in a little bit
um i mentioned earlier in the
introduction that you know we kind of
had this connection
uh through jim simons and wanting to
uh communicate some ideas or so forth
with him
i understand that you not only um
applied for a job at renaissance perhaps
uh you proposed this question that i'm
going to answer for you
uh here but also you claim that you have
a strategy which
which is uh you know which which is uh
possibly a potential interest to them so
i know that uh you know we're just
sharing this between a few thousand
close friends so yeah nobody's here
nobody's listening
well it's not so much a strategy that
would be interesting to him um but it's
reverse engineering you know he has many
strategies and he has a couple of
funds and and there was one time where
he was launching a fund that was going
to be stocks only which is unusual for
renaissance like they do
every asset class but they do a lot of
like inter-country stuff and
and currency and and and things like
that but he
at one point this is like 10 years ago
maybe a little more actually more it's
like 15 years ago
he was launching a huge huge mega fund
that was going to be
stocks only and at the time
and i think this is still the case i
think i more or less reverse engineered
the strategy
of that fund and it's not a complicated
strategy he'll basically invest in
every small to mid-size
public company that has a large amount
of cash
no debt and is either profitable or
break-even
with the idea that if they have a lot
like let's say a company
has 500 million cash no debt
and you know and they're not even that
big like let's say they're they're
they're burned before revenues is like
50 million a year
they're going to be in they're going to
be in business for a long time and so if
you combine that concept with the idea
that you know warren buffett has a
strategy
where he says if a business is going to
be still be in business 20 years from
now it's probably a good investment now
so the best way to ensure a business is
going to be in business 20 years from
now
is to look at their balance sheet and if
they have a lot of cash if they have no
debt
if they if their exp yearly expenses are
nowhere near their cash levels
probably going to be in business 20
years from now so my
thinking is and you could you could see
this by looking at
if you do you could look at it in
different what test this idea in
different ways if you look at any
company
that has a lot of cash and no debt
chances are renaissance
technologies is one of the largest
shareholders even now big companies are
small because i remember during the
the bottom of this most recent crash
that we're potentially still enduring
uh you know i looked at i talked to a
friend of mine you know
uh do you think it's a good idea to
invest in verizon or
uh for a t and he was like well let's
compare them i
i you know the street thinks verizon's a
much better bet and i said well just out
of curiosity
what is their or what's the revenue and
it's like 29 billion
holy cow that's awesome that's amazing
and i was like just
out of curiosity what's their debt and
it's like 200 billion dollars like these
companies have
multi-hundred billion dollar debt that
even if they took all their revenue
just to pay down their debt in in you
know four years they'd be bankrupt so
yeah how do these comments so it can't
apply to they can't print money it can't
apply to like
super huge companies right right no i i
don't think you know so for that type
of company he probably has other funds
and other strategies it's just
specifically this one um fund
i was reverse engineering and i noticed
because i always like at this time this
is like 14 or 15 years ago i always like
companies
that have a large amount of cash and no
debt i'm very uh
uh risk averse so uh
you know and again it's it's hard to
piece through his filings because they
his biggest funds own hundreds and
hundreds of
companies so it's hard to necessarily
find them but if you look at even
smaller or medium-sized companies and
again if you do a search on
if there's various stock screeners out
there if you do a search on
companies that have again large cash
zero debt
so usually like mid-sized companies or
maybe they might even be biotech
companies
uh biotech companies really you know
research companies don't really take on
a lot of debt
he's usually he's renaissance
technologies is usually one of the major
shareholders but but now he's got you
know
tens of billions of dollars in this fund
so he he
he has to be in hundreds of stocks but
there are hundreds of small to
medium-sized companies that have a lot
of cash and no debt
and so i just figured that was the basic
strategy and he figured it's a strategy
he doesn't have to really
focus on too much it's very simple like
just make sure they're not going out of
business
well no debt a lot uh they have expenses
to go for
at least you know five to ten years
whatever his uh thing is and that's
that was my reverse engineered approach
and i only noticed it
not by studying what companies he was
invested in but that i noticed that
every company
i was interested in using these metrics
he seemed to be invested in
and when i looked at companies that
didn't have those metrics he wasn't
invested in
so that's that's was my sort of reverse
engineering there now for his
main hedge fund uh which he's had since
the
early 90s or i i think was like the
early 90s
when he started that's a much more
complicated um
uh algorithmic like arbitrage between
currencies and
things like that that's right that's the
so he was implementing idea sex before
the idea for idea sex was hatched in
your idea yeah
uh so i mean basically for a long time
as i understand you know greg zuckerman
who i guess is a friend of yours and a
friend of mine
he wrote his autobiography his biography
um of jim simons which
you know it's funny because jim comments
on the i don't think it's a very good
book in my podcast
so i don't know if i'm going to send
this to greg uh who's a good friend
uh but the uh but the but the point was
you know back
in the day people say how do they do it
and and uh you know how do they
consistently do it's one thing to do
well
and and so i asked him like how do you
do it what's the secret give us the
secret sauce right now no so i didn't
ask him that
but i said you know it's it's
interesting because what renaissance did
for the first time
as he explained it to me and i parsed it
through the all toucher filter of idea
sex
back then there was like uh technical
analysis which is like looking at charts
i
i mean you know much more about hedge
funds than i do i never ever know but
there's technical analysis and there's
fundamental analysis
so and and there's and there's
quantitative analysis which is different
than technical analysis right so that
was technical analysis
he would not do i doubt correct unless
he unless he misinterpreted and thought
you said quantitative analysis
tech analysis for people like that and
and for
and even for me like it's [ __ ] like
that doesn't really yeah it's like this
for seriously
leaves and right but but applying the um
the quantitative analysis
had never been done to something that
has fundamental analysis so i'll give
you an example
um you know he would look at you know uh
pork bellies or whatever
and he would do that and he would do a
quantitative regression analysis
against the turkish lira you know
whatever and and there'd be some
advantage and
in in our discussions like all we needed
was you know a point zero zero one
percent advantage because we have so
much capital
that we can exploit that level as long
as it's fifty point zero zero zero
one percent probability of of success we
would put a ton of cash
behind it because they had a ton of cash
so it was kind of like card counting in
blackjack like you only and
in the best card counters like let's
talk ed thorpe who was the original card
counter and who was uh
right who was uh one of their sub
headphones i think but but but he
he basically you would just need a like
you say a 0.01
advantage and that's when you know to
start betting huge
yeah and so so yeah the combining this
kind of fundamental analysis like
if there's a drought in peru then you
know peruvian wheat is i'm just
i have no idea what the hell i'm talking
about but but that will go down so
that's a fundamental thing you can just
look at the now the one thing that they
did have for decades
was they actually had like newspaper
clippings you know going back to
whatever the 1930s
and so they could do these regression
analyses as far as i understand it
uh for a long time and and i think that
was one of the
one of the major advantages that they
had and again you just need this
fraction of a percent advantage
if you have the cash flow to stay alive
and that's the hard thing i think
and so because they had the first mover
advantage because they had the idea sex
of
a quantitative plus fundamental for the
first time really
they really came to monopolize that
space and and have done really well
and so yeah that is a great book uh that
i i know jim doesn't
and actually one of the things we'll
talk about the very end is kind of
legacies and books and so forth
uh today's podcast but yeah go ahead you
know another
i'll just reverse engineer a little bit
of
at least renaissance's early strategies
i don't know if they still do this but
like
just take the idea of quantitative
analysis for a second i'll make it very
simple
let's say you know canada and the united
states are essentially
the same country financially like if the
u.s does well canada's going to do well
if canada does well the u.s is going to
do well um
so if if one if two days in a row canada
goes up
and the u.s goes down then it's almost
common sense okay
u.s just went down they should be going
up and down together but if u.s goes
down two days in a row canada goes up
they've diverged
so now snap them back together so buy
the us and short canada
so you actually take very little risk
because country markets don't really
move
that much versus stocks and you have the
extra advantage that
you've seen and so really quantitative
analysis you've statistically back
tested
well the last 500 times canada went up
two days
when the us went down two days if you
buy the u.s the next day and you short
you sell canada the next day they'll
snap back together so you do
all sorts of you find all sorts of pairs
like that that are statistically
related now people used to do uh if
they're fundamentally really like
if gm goes up and forward goes down but
you know
then you snap them together but you but
it's much better to do it where it's
statistically related because
there's interesting things that happen
because canada and the us are also very
different
canada is a natural resources country
the us isn't so
canada and canada is a an ex-british
country you us is but not as much as
canada
and australia which is also a resources
company a country
so you can you can do the same arbitrage
with canada and australia
so sometimes australia has a bigger
gravitational pull on canada and
sometimes the u.s does and you could
statistically model that all out
and that's what i believe simon started
off with
on his uh quantitative arbitrage
strategies and he would always do
arbitrage
so you would take very little risk like
a strategy like that
uh in 2008 which was even when things
were hugely volatile
after the bankruptcy of lehman brothers
that was actually a very successful
strategy
yeah yeah i agree and you know i had on
my podcast
um twice already eric weinstein oh yes
super smart guy super smart and he was
uh he's a managing director of teal
capital
i know you're close with peter thiel and
you've had him on the show um
and eric and i were talking and one of
the things he says to me is is
you know i had an idea for an un
unsinkable
or undefeatable arbitrage strategy and
when i went to work he was working on
wall street and hedge fund
before teal capital in the in the late
90s or something like that
and he said you know it was like the
right of passage you know you show up
for work and the first day of the hedge
fund
they'd say you got any killer ideas and
everybody would say i've got this idea
for this three-way arbitrage you know
triple
triplet uh of of of uh currencies you
know that we could make arbitrage bets
on and win
and they just started like cackling at
him and you know saying oh that's a rook
such a rookie mistake it's like hazing
uh for hedge fund geeks and uh he was
just like
they tried to convince him that that
trade would only was correct the math
was 100 correct
but it would never work because they
didn't have the the resources to go
behind it so
uh unlike ren it wasn't renaissance but
uh yeah so there is you know never under
i always say that you know
quantity has a quality all of its own
you know it's not just like oh we want
to spend quality time with my kid of
course yeah
but quantity of time is equally
important and and we'll get into
fatherhood because
you and i are both fathers of five and i
want to
uh pick your brain about fatherhood as
we go up and you know what though it's
it's
i i could go on and on about the hedge
fund strategies because that's such a
fascinating topic i'm sure eric uh had
some you know in the late 90s in
particular in the early 00s
still people had not implemented these
quant
strategies there was maybe renaissance
and there was a company called aqr
there's very few quant funds out there
so there was opportunity and by the way
there were also scam opportunities that
were
that were under-regulated so so one
strategy in the 90s that was brilliant
that unfortunately
you know it was you know i wasn't even
aware of it but
people made hundreds of millions of
dollars and then it got regulated and
those people just
disappeared like they're they're gone
with their billions or whatever
but you it was it was a strategy called
playing the calendar
so you would open up an account at
goldman sachs and you would just
trade millions of shares of stock
generating lots of fees for the brokers
and the goal was to lose as little money
as possible
so you would so the brokers would end up
with these huge fees and you would
hopefully not lose so much money
and then when there was a big ipo that
happened like ebay
you know in the not late 90s you you
would you would say to your broker hey
you just generated you know several
hundred thousand dollars in fees i want
the biggest allocation possible from
ebay
and and and you would get it and you
would sell it would go up
300 the first day and you would sell
even though you're not really supposed
to sell the first day they would try to
make you sign something not to sell the
first day
but because you were generating so many
fees they would let you get away with it
and it's called playing the calendar
because you'd open up accounts depending
on
which bank's doing what ipo on what day
yeah
and i know that you've uh you were
not only deeply involved in this hedge
fund world but you also
uh were one of the writers on the head
show billions on each
on um show time i was a an advisor yeah
advisor besides the writers yeah
and one of my favorite things so i'm
going to take uh the jim simons episode
of into the impossible
and divide it up into little clips like
you've taught us how to do
so spectacularly successfully i'm going
to take this uh
take these clips and and one of them is
going to be called you know
jim simons on this one weird tip that'll
make you really no
it's it's going to be where he goes
through and explains you know alpha
and beta and that was actually your
question we'll get to that in a second
yeah uh but he gets to you know this
description
of what is alpha and he thinks about it
mathematically
and and geometrically actually and we'll
describe that and so it's unique and i
really felt like
little goosebumps you know as he's
describing it kind of like einstein let
me just give you a lecture on you know
relativity and the speed of light
uh much better than brian keating could
ever do but jane i i doubt that because
you you were explaining it to me i do my
best and we'll talk about pedagogy and
academia because i know you've got so
many thoughts about that as well but
getting back to jim
he goes through this you know
description and and
and then i was looking up because i knew
you had been an advisor to billions so i
looked at billions
and uh and james altucher and it comes
up with a with a blog post
uh from a few years back and basically
in the blog post
you basically say that almost every
hedge fund is crooked and
and you have this this story about you
know you applied for a job with a
certain uh securities
dealer firm and you were rejected and we
deal a lot with rejection fear of
rejection i wonder if you could tell
that story and whether or not you think
because you basically accuse most hedge
funds of doing something crooked or
illicit
and the question is does that apply do
you think to renaissance uh but first
why don't you tell your quick story uh
about your
misadventures with applying for a job
and getting rejected it must really
sting looking back in retrospect
yeah so um i mean i have a bunch of
rejection stories
uh uh i have a renaissance rejection
story are we talking about that yeah
no no do that one uh do do that one
first and then there's another one with
a guy named bernie something yeah yeah
first dude first new gym
so so i wrote you know i was doing all
these quantitative strategies and i was
um and actually other quant based hedge
fund managers were investing with me
so uh i wrote to jim simons i figured
out his email address you know you kind
of
uh look you google at
renaissancetechnologies.com all over the
internet and you see how they format
their emails and then i wrote i figured
out how
uh how to write jim so i wrote to him i
describe my background i describe my
strategies
and he's like this is great you should
come in and and talk to us we'd love to
i'd love to meet you
um and at this point i had also written
a book about quant strategies it was my
very first book
called trade like a hedge fund and and
then he's and then i forget who brought
it up
i think he asked but wait uh do you have
a phd uh he said i noticed you went to
graduate school at carnegie mellon do
you have a phd
and i said actually i got thrown out of
carnegie mellon so i never got the phd
and he's like we oh it's a rule we only
hire phds
i don't think that's correct i actually
i think i think there might have been
other ideas but
when was this again james that was like
2004.
um well maybe they still did but um but
soon after that they stopped because i i
had a whole bunch of grad students that
wanted to get jobs with him and he
at the end he was just like no we've got
too many phds we've got too many
eggheads basically
and we need some people to understand
business but that's funny so it could
have been a pretext but who knows yeah
yeah maybe yeah and then another time i
was raising money for a hedge fund
and my neighbor says to me hey i work
for this one guy he's really nice why
don't you come in
so we go in and uh his boss gives me
a tour of the office a great guy he's
explains everything
we go into his office and he says okay
james what can i do for you and i said
well
uh i was i have a different strategy i
think than you
and why don't you i was hoping you could
invest money with me
and you know we can figure out that the
details i'll give you a break on fees or
give you equity in the fundraiser
he said listen i'm sorry if you
if you want to work here you know i like
you
you're smart you're friends with danny
the guy who brought you in uh
you could get a job we will hire you any
day you want
but i don't know where you put your
money i don't know where you invest
so the last in many points himself he
says the last thing we need here
at bernard made off securities is to see
bernard made off securities llc on the
front page of the wall street journal
so uh and then i was crushed like i
thought like oh
he rejected me and he's got better
returns than me
how am i ever gonna compete in this
industry like i couldn't raise money and
uh i actually got out of i started the
process of shutting down my hedge fund
after that because of bernie madoff
so you you benefited from his investing
advice
you know what's funny too is that after
he was exposed he was exposed like three
three or four years later so after he
was exposed uh
everyone all my friends in the business
was like oh we totally knew he was a
scam
and and i said no you know i remember
when i was walking into the building you
were calling me
and begging me to ask him to let you
put money into his fund i don't think
you knew all along
so no not very few people knew yeah but
100
of people claim they knew oh yeah it's
like at woodstock there were 20 times
more people who thought they were there
claimed they were there
but yeah looking at him and then yeah i
mean look at that's that
medallion fund that's run by renaissance
technologies i think they've been you
know
haven't ever had a down year you know in
30 40 years whatever it's been
and uh and now no one's saying oh yeah i
knew it in a second you know
he must have been doing something
crooked um you know you know some people
some people have said to me or they've
asked me is renaissance
uh doing something uh not totally
closure
and but i was always convinced they were
completely kosher hey i knew people who
had who had worked there
b i reverse engineered at least one or
two of their strategies
and and see you know most most people
uh don't know how to research these
things so i show people
all you can see here's the whole here's
jim's you know renaissance stock
holdings like their
legit uh company so you know it's
it's fine so you asked me to ask jim a
question
about um about the difficulties in the
environment that they operate in now uh
brought about
largely by their success are they being
victimized essentially by the
proliferation of quantitative hedge
funds
and uh and and yeah essentially are they
a victim of their own success that they
really were the
kind of first movers in the space and
now there's so many quants et cetera
and so i did ask him about that and you
said your other problems capturing alpha
and it was good that you did because
that prompted him to like
let me explain alpha and let me explain
beta and you know i encourage people
listen to the podcast because he does it
in a signature way so james jim was a
was a mathematician
before he was a hedge fund pioneer he
was a mathematician
and he worked with your dad right yeah
yeah they worked together at suny stony
brook he hired my father
the gun that was their connection from
sunni from cornell where my father had
been uh
the youngest full professor ever at
cornell to come to suny stony brook to
start this fledgling math department
where they work together and jim goes so
you know describing you know alpha he's
like
he thinks about it in terms of like you
know a topographic
surface in this higher dimensional space
and he goes through like
well you have to look at you know the
properties of these of these you know
vector bundles
on top of a surface of an idealized
space and
and that these properties of alpha and
beta are orthogonal to each other
and you're looking to maximize you know
certain properties of this relationship
between
alpha and beta and it was funny james
because it was like we had the podcast i
think
i recorded two weeks ago of the fifth of
june
and the market was way up like way up
that day it was like
up 1800 points or something and he kept
just like looking over and looking and
he's like oh god
and he's like i'm like jim what's wrong
he's like you know we're getting crushed
today
and he even says it in the podcast and
i'm like you know jim if you need a
bridge loan
i'm good but i'm going to charge you you
know 4 and 40 like you guys do
yeah he didn't appreciate that but but
that's an interesting
observation on your part that he was
looking over at that and he was stressed
because the the relationship between
alpha
beta and the market is very important
and
and suggests how correlated he is with
the underlying market he's not
correlated at all to the underlying
market so a big update
depending on how his bets you know
relate to
alpha beta gamma and every and vega
it could you know he could be very he
could have a huge down day that day oh
yeah and it's and it's
and just as he can make a tremendous
amount you know leveraged against a tiny
amount
um you know of of probability above 50
50 chance
uh he also can lose a tremendous so on
that day the market's up six percent
though the journal greg zuckerman
actually reported that the fund that
he's in now so i think he's out of i
don't know if he's out of them
i don't know understand how it works but
uh but there are other funds that are
open to institutions and he has invested
in those
and he's probably their biggest investor
and so when those and greg reported that
those funds were down like 20
on the year which is like seriously
underperforming
uh the s p even and of course nobody
would expect that given
the apocalypse which we have gone
through maybe haven't gone through i
want to get your opinions on that
but yes exactly so looking at that it's
possible to like understand
both how much he views things in terms
of bets and you've had annie duke on i
know and i'm hoping to have her on my
podcast someday too
okay she's got a new book coming out
soon too so she'll be yeah
doing the rounds of podcasts yeah one of
the things you gave me an idea to do
which is like
all these authors especially the first
time authors but but even second time
authors like annie
um you know their book tours are all
cancelled so i was like uh this is my
chance to get you know people on the
show
who would never come on the show anyway
so i just pitched i'll do an intro email
if you want or maybe you've already
talked no i haven't i've talked to her
publicist but you know but i would love
an intro
uh to her um and i have some great ideas
for people that i think you'll resonate
with too
uh including eric and other people but
we'll uh we'll we can cover that offline
but he thinks about it so much in terms
of hedgehog like
if you go through i'm gonna have a video
up on our channel for the simon's
observatory which is this hundred
million dollar
project in the high atacama desert 17
000 feet above sea level in chile that
we're looking for
the uh the the signatures of the big
bang here's a little note card thank you
note oh my god
with our website on it so it's got that
we have an animated it's really cool
anyway
he's when we talk about it he's like
well and i just talked to him
last friday again to give a little
inspirational um
uh marching orders to the to the
collaboration as we endure covid
ourselves and and get through our our
our daily work
and he said you know like uh we're going
to be on this guy soon we're going to
have information about the
about the origin of the universe very
soon or we may find out that it's
uh that that it didn't have a big bang
there wasn't a thing and that's what i
prefer but i don't care because even if
i'm wrong if i'm right the universe
didn't have a big bang
there was just an infinite cycle of
creation and destruction events
uh creative destruction like the hedge
fund titan he has
but but if if it did have an origin and
you detect it then we win the nobel
prize
so he's like i'm like you even hedged
that like you you hedged your science
bets too
it's but it's funny it's clear to me
that that's the way that he analyzes
everything and it's pure but even
drilling down deeper it comes from a
basis of geometry
and the properties of the way that he
sees things i asked him in the podcast i
was like
you know oftentimes he said that a
certain thing in math will be beautiful
like the nobel prize winner paul dirac
said it's more important that your
equations
are beautiful than that they agree with
experiment i don't agree with that but
but people fall in love with this
beautiful aspects of mathematics
but he truly i said what is beautiful to
you in mathematics
and you gonna listen to the podcast when
it comes out but but basically
you know things that have a symmetry or
a beautiful unity or express some
some essence of of the un underlying
truth
those are things that can then in all
teachers speak make
make connections or network or or idea
sex that can combine
to leverage up as hedge funds do to make
a greater gain than you would have
expected like
they're there he admits he's like i
can't do math anymore
uh i haven't been able to do math for 10
years but i can still think
you know in terms of hedge funds i can
still think in terms of bats i can still
think in terms of philanthropy
but he's using these meta skills that he
that he derived and and developed
uh much younger in life as a
mathematician i also asked him
you know um do you think mathematicians
always do their best work by age 30 and
it was kind of interesting to hear
because he's in you know he's 82 years
old he smokes six packs of merit
cigarettes a day for the last six
decades
which made it really fun to take him up
to 17 000 feet on oxygen pure oxygen
tank but
he survived i took him up there last
year by the way on that question
you know i've read something recently
gosh i forget where i read it
but i read a a a book about that very
question and they pointed or
a chapter on that question they pointed
out how einstein
actually his most cited work was when he
was in i believe in his 40s
yeah so it was some of his analysis on
quantum mechanics like in the 20s
yeah he did he did so in 1905 he was 25
years old so
you know that's the miracle year but you
know 10 years later he was 35
and doing much more technical
mathematics i mean the special theory of
relativity
the constancy of the speed of light
length contraction time dilation
those are those are mathematic but the
the equations are algebra basically
um a little geometry uh pythagorean
theorem with an
what's called a hyperbolic geometry but
um but for
general relativity i mean he had to
basically invent new mathematics or
apply
things from like 1800s and what's called
differential geometry the same kind of
map that jim
simon's traffic's in and uh so i think
that was really interesting
he did say that it is harder to to you
know just to answer your question you
know give you a preview of the episode
that it is harder now because of you
know firms like renaissance and others
to really capture alpha while preserving
beta you know or minimizing beta
volatility
and uh but you know it's kind of like we
were reminded of uh super computers so
the
moore's laws you know is this
exponential growth is this you know
increasing exponential as our mutual
friend
peter diamandis loves to talk about and
that's one of the
uh properties of technology when it
becomes demonetized and democratized
but one of the ds that actually the d in
democratization
means that the utility function is
higher so the reason that the total
amount of compute computations isn't
really increasing
worldwide even though the speed of each
individual computer
and the speed of the fastest computer uh
on earth is not uh benefiting to the
extent that you would predict based on
moore's law
it's because there's a util there's a
usage penalty like the more powerful the
computer gets the more people want to
use it
and and so it gets a subscription tax
and it can't because there's an overhead
associated with each process or job as
they call it
and and then the processing within each
process also has a tax and overhead
so um so even though the the fundamental
unit of computation is getting better
and better
it's getting it's also a victim of its
own success so we related it to that
and so there's more of them and so it's
harder and harder to find opportunities
uh but and it's harder to maximize what
mathematicians call the surprise like
you know it's not a surprise if i say
you know florida's pretty hot
and humid right now j like that doesn't
tell you so you're not surprised to hear
that
um and so i've revealed i've
communicated information
but it doesn't have any utility so in
this case with computers
they're getting faster and faster or
with hedge funds more and more of them
but uh but the underlying revelation of
new information
is is constant or maybe it's declining
so
in some ways for their flagship funds i
don't think that they've really suffered
at all because of this
whereas the institutional funds
according to greg zuckerman
they they have because they're they're
competing you know
he said in the in the medallion fund
they can do 90
they could be as much as 90 short i
think uh at a given time
and uh but in the uh you know for every
dollar uh they could also they could go
at 90
90 short or something like that uh
whereas for the institutional fund
i think he told me that it's like five
percent so you don't have it's
asymmetric
wagering like you can't really exploit a
surprise function
benefit to your advantage yeah and he
you know it's it's tricky though
i'm still intrigued where he finds
i mean he he's not going to really give
the real answer because that's how he
makes billions of dollars
so but i'm intrigued i'm curious what
his process now is for finding alpha
because
it's very it's very difficult like every
there's kind of been a race to the
bottom on every strategy so like for in
take take as an example this canada us
arbitrage strategy i described before
well if everybody knew that strategy and
it's not such a complicated strategy
then you know right as soon as the the
divergence happens everybody jumps in
and snaps it back together there's no
more
arbitrage right so you know i remember
one time
i had a strategy that was literally it
was like an atm machine this strategy
works so well so it was
basically if the nasdaq was gapping up
in the morning
between 0.4 and 0.6 percent
i could short it at 9 30 a.m and within
a half hour it was gonna go back to even
at some point and i would
i was done for the day and so i wrote
about this on an article
on a financial website and somebody
called me up
who was working on the strategy with me
and other strategies
and he said what did you just do why did
you just
and i'm like nah no one's gonna play it
and the market's huge like you think
just a few readers are gonna
squash this out strategy never worked
again
it worked it literally had to work 99
times out of the prior 100 times
and then it never worked again well they
talk about jim talks about
in i think in greg's book how there are
certain signals you know they describe
everything in terms of signals
uh which is you know some correlation
analysis must be used for that and uh
he says he's got some signals that like
haven't ever not worked
now you know for the medallion fund as i
understand it
uh you know so there's signals to go
back 30 40 50 years you just got to
wonder what the hell is like still
correlated you know that is it contains
the surprise entropy you know that's
like a discovery that only they know and
of course they're not going to say what
it is
uh so i thought it was really
interesting but really to see how he
does things
and i also talked a lot about him about
academia and leadership
and and kind of got his his notion of
what um of of you know kind of what his
role model is for a leader and i wonder
have you had on doris kearns goodwin i
forgot
no you know and i've considered having
her on
and for some reason i didn't i don't
know
i forget why so i thought of a way that
you could get her on which is that i'll
send you the link to obviously the to
the video gym but i asked him
what uh who's your favorite historical
figure of all time and he said without a
hesitation lincoln i was like well
you know why not euclid or you know his
boat is named after archimedes his
famous quote
uh you know eureka his boat is called
eureka because you know that's what the
archimedes said when he got into the tub
allegedly
uh it floats but um but then i asked him
because i was like i gotta get doris
kearns goodwin on the show so i was like
any good books you can recommend
and he said oh yeah yeah dora's
current's goodwood so what i'll do is
i'll send you because
you can get i can't get access to her
but i'll send you the link and just say
like
the world's most brilliant billionaire
uh as uh
obsessed with your work or whatever
would love to have your conversation
yeah we talk about it so i'll send you
yeah that's a great idea lincoln
what was it um her book about lincoln a
team of rivals
yeah right so it specifically refers to
his leadership strategy which is to have
kind of this discourse which is
something that which never happens in
american politics
since which is to have discourse among
people who disagree with each other
because
he needed that kind of consensus to to
to lead in such a difficult time
and i said to him look you know what you
were also before you were leading these
hedge funds and so forth
you were the the chairman of the
inaugural chairman of the suny stony
brook math department
and what was your strategy there because
i had asked him you know we were on the
trip
to chile last year you know about this
kind of what's his leadership strategy
and he also mentioned a book
and i can't find the name this book but
it's um it's a fictional book
it's called like captain or the captain
it must have come out in the 60s or
whatever
and it's about a naval captain a
fictional story about this naval captain
who's like
exemplary you know in terms of
leadership and building consensus
but then jim's strategy in some sense
was to
let people you know passionately decide
the things they're passionate about
you know it's like he would let them
kind of burn out their energy and they'd
have squabble we want to hire this
person in
in integral analysis you know whatever
uh at the math department but then
there's something that was really
important to him
then he would speak up and because he
didn't you know waste all of his
political capital so to speak
on the decisions that he really didn't
care about i mean you could hire
somebody good and another
he didn't really care but when it came
to something or some decision
or some new program or course or
whatever that he really cared about
then he would lay down his marker and he
had a lot more chips really stashed up
and he's you know in some sense he
learned that from this book captain
which i gotta find
um and uh so maybe we can get a
researcher
listening out there to do that but um
but yeah i thought it was really
interesting that he's had success in
three different fields
that's so rare i mean most people are
lucky to have half a career
and wait three fields there's hedge
funds there's the math
and philanthropy okay and according to
greg he's also he's a code breaker but
you know he famously got fired for
opposing
nixon's you know secretary of war or
whatever in the 70s from this institute
for defense analysis he really didn't
last very long as a code breaker
but he was you know officially that was
his one of his early careers um
but i really think of him as this you
know unique individual for being
achieving the highest level of success
winning the highest prize
you know there is no nobel prize in
mathematics and he won
this prize that second you know only to
to something like that or the fields
medal called the veblen prize when he
was young
and then he uh and then obviously he
went on to start the uh
the renaissance technologies and also to
uh to begin the simon's foundation which
has this unique mission
in an academic research of fundamental
research which is
only to research thing you know it's
often said that the problem with
basic science is that it produces
technology like
like if it didn't you wouldn't expect
like where's this fast like what is
studying the big bang gonna teach you
about
about you know getting a faster cell
phone nothing but if you look back
the same laboratory that where the cmb
the classic microwave background was
discovered
was bell laboratories and it's not an
accident because these scientists were
serendipitously came upon the signal
they were trying to get rid of this
noise
uh in the first communication satellite
so that was like again it's kind of like
idea sex you've got
you know this basic you know problem
where you want to reduce noise you're
looking at things that are floating
around in space
and then accidentally you never know and
that's the problem serendipity is by
definition a surprise and it's
unexpected
and there they flip things around and
say we're going to fund things that have
high likelihood of success
but are also potential sources to unlock
serendipity
and i thought you know right now we
could get into talking a little bit
about academia
because you know you you talk a lot
about uh your academic
uh pedigree and uh and your famous stuff
and lack thereof and and that cost you a
job probably both at bernie madoff
securities and that
renaissance but right uh but i think
you'll yeah
you've done okay for yourself um but the
uh but academia you know it's kind of
this interesting
thing where it clashes to be you know
with all due respect it clashes with a
lot of the advice that you give and
and and potentially has these challenges
especially what i do in terms of
experimental physics so
i want to segue into that first i want
to preface this but you know if gavin
newsom
my ultimate boss is listening you know i
love my job i would do it you know i'm
gonna keep doing i'm not going anywhere
uh but um you know you talk a lot about
this this
the the essence of experiments and uh
and why the ten thousand hour rule
isn't really so applicable anymore you
talk about the 10 000
experiments role um i i like to say that
it's not 10 000
hours for me it was 13 billion years so
you know
that's i had to work that long no so but
this is why we had the conversation on
my podcast where i was asking you
do you really need the math to be a good
physicist
because what if someone had the ideas
like like conceptually i could you could
imagine
we can do thought experiments about 10
different ways the universe could have
started
and then you know the math could sort of
take care of itself with a mathematician
and then focus on the experimental stuff
without knowing any math
i thought more about that and i was
thinking like let's say you look at this
this glass apple that my wife got me for
my birthday
um or my maybe is my in-laws was that
like your dream gift like she got oh
yeah
the solid diamond this is amazing okay
yeah yeah so uh
you know i was thinking like well let's
say you like isaac asimov i know
um let's let's say you know you you um
you're looking at the earth and asimov
said something like to the effect that
if you think that the earth is a sphere
you're wrong um but you're less wrong
than if you think the earth is flat like
the job of science is to really not
necessarily come up with like something
extremely brand new and and some people
say like lee smullin who's a a brilliant
um professor friend of mine at the
perimeter institute which is a
really interesting kind of like very
unusual think tank
uh started from funds from blackberry
incorporated rim and that's why it's
called perimeter
but anyway um lee smalling doesn't even
think the scientific method exists or in
some sense but
but getting back to asimov so like would
you know
enough like just as a layperson to say
well like
the earth isn't a sphere like i bet you
thought the earth probably is a sphere
right i mean it's sort of well you know
this is a great question because if if
let's say we
were transported 3000 years in the past
okay it looks to me like the earth is
flat
yeah oh absolutely like i would have
told my students james i tell my
students can you prove to me
you now have your phd like on the day of
their i'm such a
you know a piece of you know what but
but anyway i say to them like
you're now a card-carrying phd in
astrophysics
i believe that the earth is the center
of the universe prove me wrong
and very few i mean i have some
brilliant brilliant students and it
doesn't matter ucsd it could be
princeton
it's very hard to do but the reason it's
hard to do because people
are ignorant in some sense of history
and they don't understand how do we come
to know what we know
but they certainly have these lacunae
these gaps in their knowledge
and i think yeah it looks like it but
the looks can be deceiving that's why
you don't trust your eyes you build
tools and telescopes to
augment your eyes but go on yeah yeah
but like even talk you know you were
you mentioned eric weinstein earlier
who's you know got his training in
physics and math and so on and you know
it's hard for people to start with first
principles because we don't know we kind
of like you say we forgot what they what
they are we kind of start
with we already know about gravity and
we already know about
galileo and that's kind of just baked
into like just
the intro or the forward of our physics
books like if i
you know you ever read a connecticut
yankee in king arthur's court by samuel
clemens
by mark twain yeah right yeah so so so
so i always wonder if i had to go in
time to king arthur's court
i'm gonna just die because there's
nothing
i can do i don't even i wouldn't even be
able to teach them how to boil an
egg like or make toast or and that guy
strung together like phone networks and
he made guns for them
like i wouldn't have been able to do any
of that
there's a book um it's like one of these
prepper books or whatever but
it's basically it has that as a thesis
like yeah how to embed everything yeah
how do i invent everything right yeah
i think i think that's really funny but
yeah getting into science like can a lay
person do this we talked about the
podcast
you it's like you don't even know enough
and that's not an insult it's just like
that's not your
skill stack right i mean right you you
need to know
so much about like well why is the earth
not a perfect sphere and and that
connects to celestial mechanics and the
rotation
and also the plate tectonics like
there's so many meta things that go into
it
um nobody would would say like in other
words
it appears that the illusion is so
strong once you overcome the illusion
that the earth is flat
the uh the attraction to this beautiful
idea of perfect symmetry
is very strong and so it's very
resilient to
to disruption to changes in the way that
we think about things so
i do think it's hard to to really break
out of that paradigm but but what i want
to talk about
you know next with you is is um
you know as i said i'm not going
anywhere gavin you know don't worry
but um and actually i was thinking you
know like you know what the proof that
being a professor is the best job that
there is
james uh
you ca you can you could basically can
live in a science fiction world
and you you have job security for life
from it yeah
that's one thing but you know what the
proof text as we would say you know
talmudically is
uh you know what uh the most famous
human being who ever lived
you know born at least after the last
couple of the last couple hundred years
do you know what he did
neil armstrong after he landed came back
from landing on the moon
he became a professor at the university
of cincinnati so
yeah he became an engineering professor
at the university of cincinnati
and he lasted at that job it was like a
year or two after he
had walked on the surface of the moon
and reached heights that no human being
had ever reached uh he did that he
taught he didn't get tenure he got no
i'm just kidding
i think he did he had a phd too didn't
he i don't know if he did neil um
buzz aldrin does from mit and aerospace
engineering
i don't think he did no he was the test
pilot um i'm sure that's something
wikipedia can tell me while you answer
the next question
the next question is about academia
being like kind of the
the uh bizarro world of choosing
yourself and that
you know we talked about this a little
bit on your podcast but i want to
explore it a little bit more deeply and
that we have a little more time
you know first step you're in high
school you got to get into college
and there's a gatekeeper there uh once
you get into college you have to do well
you have to
take gres get into graduate school these
are all the steps to become a professor
that i went through
uh grad school you have to do well have
a good thesis have a good advisor
he or she has to be connected help you
land a next job
um and then you have to do well in that
job that's called a post-doctoral
scholarship
fellowship that's kind of this purgatory
between being a graduate student and
being a professor when you have to show
your medal
and show your worth and creativity as an
independent scholar
that's when i got fired from stanford uh
when i was a postdoc because i
talk about you were you really depressed
then um you imagined it was
liberated no i felt liberated like and
now i'm free
i can do you know it ended up being you
know i wouldn't be talking to you i
wouldn't be married i wouldn't
you know who knows maybe i would but but
uh but the
looking back at life uh it it couldn't
have happened any other way
at first obviously it was devas like
stanford university it's one of the best
places in the world to be
it has this prestige ranking off the
charts and to get fired
but uh but i was unhappy there it was
like 1999
in silicon valley making 32 thousand
dollars a year as a postdoc
living six miles away on the caltrains
line where the trains were running back
then every 15 minutes
from you know five in the morning till
midnight and so i didn't sleep more than
five hours the whole year i was there
before i got fired but
getting back to postdocs so you're
postdoc you do well you're competing
against your postdoctoral advisor at
some level because you know
he or she has to get funding and get
tenure him or herself then you gotta
have to get a faculty job there's 400
application we had a job opening this
year
400 applications for one position you
have to get through that gate
uh then you have to get uh funding
because you only get a certain amount of
uh of startup fuel
uh you know funding from the university
that's going down because budget's going
down
um then you have to you know apply the
national science foundation get a grant
that's about 15 if you're lucky and that
you have to get past
all these gatekeepers and possible
trolls and people that are your
competitors that are reviewing your pool
then you get through then you have to
get 10 years you have a permanent then
you can do you know
ultimate freedom but now you're you've
invested about 20
years in higher education it's not just
that too you're
you're always ranked according to how
many citations are exactly yeah so that
was the that was the
next thing i want to talk about there's
something called the h index we'll get
into these meta
rankings of how you assess quality of
academia
and what your note like how you would uh
an alternative to it
in the rapid fire section we'll get to
that um and then you can't choose
yourself that was the one rule they gave
me
at the nobel prize that they still
adhere to they forgot about every other
rule or ignore every role that alfred
nobel had
and that's that you can't choose
yourself literally you cannot choose
yourself to win
so these are all the gates these are all
the hurdles right
but but they are but let me ask you this
and this is an important question
they are the gates to what yeah so so
to you know for any metric of success i
think um
not getting tenure is almost like i
don't want to say something horrible but
but it's it's like losing something like
losing a pet
you know it's it's devastating and and
it's it's a huge investment like you put
in a lot of
uh tremendously you've moved you've had
your family you've done
like and so that's a very important
marker yes you know there's many ways
and outcomes after graduate school
but if you want to take the path that
i've been you know i view that i've
lived this hunger games basically and
and i just happen to be lucky i don't
attribute it to my own brilliance but
you know i have certain skills i know
but uh but they're the meta skills
they're not really the skills of like
i'm super brilliant in solving this
differential equation in a matrix
algebra
breaks yeah those aren't my my core
strengths and so
what i wonder is like yeah so the metric
of
of success is this you know at least
that that getting yeah you don't have a
nobel prize but if you don't get tenure
uh that's pretty devastating and and
actually you don't get find out until
you
if you got tenure until you're in your
late 30s maybe early 40s think about
starting your life all over again yeah
it sounds romantic but you've had 20
years in higher education 22 years of
higher education
it's hard not to feel like you're a
failure at that sure sure
because because like very specifically
answer the question this is the path or
the gateway
to what well i i think you know
what people want to do if you want to be
a scientist it's very difficult in the
1800s you could get
you know do a small experiment and find
electricity emanating from a spark gap
or whatever
but what could make the steam engine he
was just uh like a mechanic
yeah right or the wright brothers could
invent an airplane and their bicycle
they owned a bicycle shop
right so so the the low-hanging fruit
has been plucked and
i guess the question is if you're
addicted to science if you love science
and you're good you're just good
but like there's some person who's on
your tenure committee who's going to
choose you and you'll never know who she
or she was
but i'm still going to dispute the
answer to the question it's not really
to be a scientist
it's to be a tenured professor
in a science department at a college
because then to be a scientist you still
have to
raise money you still have to manage a
team
pick the team you know publish more to
get you know uh
you know people attracted to working
with you so so
specifically what you described was a
gateway to being
a an associate professor at
a a university and but there are but but
but and so the argument is that's the
only path
even though you gave me an example of
neil armstrong obviously didn't take
that path but
he became a tenured professor at a
university so but let's say he's
let's say he's an outlier there's
outliers in other industries like
michael dukakis is a tenured professor
at harvard
because he ran for president he doesn't
have a phd but he ran for president
so that quality so we can we could come
up with outlier anecdotes of people who
did not take the path
you rigidly described to get to be
associated with this but let's just
assume they're
outliers yep but there's also
the fact that you have like take neil
degrasse tyson
who's you know a very smart astronomer
cosmologist world's most famous
scientist in human history yes
right but if he did not have a phd he
could still do
what he does like you know his i would
argue
he is i don't know since i don't know
the science part
i would argue he has just as much
communication skills or more he's a
media
he's a charismatic media personality and
the head of the hayden planetarium right
yeah so so and then and you know uh then
there's also guys like uh
dan carlin has one of the most popular
podcasts on the planet called hardcore
history
and when he's when he started that
podcast
it started because he and he lives in
montana he was always arguing at the
dinner table
uh about history and he was like really
into all these like
esoteric ancient wars that nobody's ever
heard of and
his i think his mother said you should
just start a podcast he's like i can't
do that i'm not i don't have a phd in
history
but he did it he chose himself without
the phd
and he has like the most popular history
podcast on the planet the fact that
great living
yeah the fact that you can name these
few people speaks to the survivorship
bias i mean there's many more people
let's say you wanted to teach
at a universe at a college level let's
just forget about university where
there's even more hurdles to getting
grants and getting papers
you know teaching college you know some
school where they don't give up phds
necessarily
um you know it's terminal degree to get
a bachelor's degree
uh that's might be all you ever wanted
to do and you wanted to teach and yeah
you could maybe you could get a job
and and teach teach high school i'm not
denigrating that at all i mean my
greatest inspirations early on we're
high school teachers
but if that is your goal if you see your
your a core identity of who you are
as a teacher as a giver as someone who
loves and i was having this conversation
earlier
you know there's one book in the whole
federal registry
of documents you know this covers the
irs the fcc the sec
like all the different federal
three-letter agencies there's one book
where you'll find
in order to succeed in this particular
field you'll find maslow's hierarchy of
needs and you'll find the words like
your students need to feel loved and i'm
just curious
like do you think that's the irs like
where do you feel where do you think
like the word love
and and and cia what's that cia
definitely
because you're recruiting uh foreign
agents and they need
you know nobody in general nobody
cares that the u.s gets information but
they want their
self-worth to be higher so your cia
tells them and says you're going to be a
general in the cia if you give me
information and they love it
well that that may be true but i i'm
sure you're right but
but where i found it is in my side
pursuit my side hustle
is wanting to someday be a flight
instructor and to be a flight instructor
you have to pass several different gates
including being a private pilot a
commercial pilot
but then you have to understand the the
theory of pedagogy which
i was never taught as a professor like
no one ever taught me like your students
need to feel safe they need to be
fed they need to have like their
physical physiological needs met like
i never knew that and i thought well why
is it for the faa you know like
irs doesn't have this like to be a kind
of general you know tax auditor you know
you really
no they don't care they just go off and
ream you right uh but but the but the
problem is you know for
them the cost of a mistake in learning
process
for a student of aviation is death and
and possibly killing other people
so it's no surprise in some sense that
you'll find it there whereas
you know we kind of say in academia like
ah my student doesn't get in like i once
thought and this is a crazy stupid idea
but
i was like how do i know that i made a
difference in a student like what's my
metric
for success when i was teaching as a
graduate student i had a nasa fellowship
to go out to like kindergartens and
teach them about space and nasa and i
was like
how the heck do i know if i'm going to
have an influence on this person if i
teach them
that there's only eight planets as there
are now in the solar system
and and somebody comes back when they're
25 and says how many planets are there
you know they could have learned that
from anybody but if i teach them there's
only
four planets you know like and then at
age 25 someone
how many planets are there four planets
then on brian keating i had a great
i never did that don't get me wrong uh
but like it's very hard to to be a good
educator and yet
we don't really teach it and so someone
who by definition wants to teach at a
teaching college or
you know college just and they don't get
to it it's
i don't say catastrophic it is
devastating and so
what advice can you give yeah that's a
very very
very specific goal right so it's someone
who is a
professor teacher um doing
scientific research and and at a good
school then you need all the things that
that you described and you need you need
a few more um you know
like you said you need to raise grant
money and so on so so that's a very
specific thing so if i wanted to be a
brain surgeon
yes i need i can't be a brain surgeon
without a medical degree by by the law
if i wanted to give medical advice
though i don't have to get a medical
degree
like i maybe i could read a ton of books
about
brain surgery and even give just as good
or even better advice
as than a brain surgeon i just wouldn't
be able to legally do
brain surgery or you know i've
given because i have experience in a
couple different areas i've given
lectures at law firms and i've been a
consultant for law firms not because i'm
a lawyer
i don't i've never taken a law class in
my life but some areas of the law i know
as well as any other lawyer and in fact
i'm able to give lectures on it
so or you know the same thing goes for
you know it depends on the field
but and it depends on the type of
regulations with the licensing
and and you know to be a tenured
professor scientist
teacher is almost as as
hardcore and it's almost like it's
regulated like any other licensing is
there's yeah but if you wanted to take
the skills of a physicist
there's many things you could do you
could work at a hedge fund you could
work at spacex you could work at google
you know there's you could even be doing
physics at google or
or a hedge fund or spacex like let's say
a hedge fund is thinking about
you know high speed frequency you know
high frequency trading
they're dealing at the quantum level and
you might need some physics to get an
edge for a hedge fund at that level
so you know there there's you're
thinking a very specific
thing yeah where yes you it's but even
then we found exceptions you know neil
armstrong michael dukakis
there might there's probably more
exceptions and if you go down the chain
on the quality of this the school we're
going to find more and more exceptions
like i can't teach physics but maybe i
could teach some other class
without any higher education degree at a
community college
so you know if we lower the quality of
the school it opens up
the the the outliers yeah so i think
to say yes i can't choose myself
to be a medical brain surgeon at
the the cleveland clinic but i can
um if i'm obsessed with medicine
and i read all the books and i study
things and i read all the latest
journals i might know even more
than you know they always say a doctor
has the most amount of knowledge the day
they graduate medical school
but if i'm obsessed with medicine maybe
i might know more
than a doctor even if i haven't
practiced it in a
surgical setting and then i don't have a
degree
or practice right right because i'm not
legally allowed
but maybe like if a family member has a
problem and they call me i mean i'm not
saying
me specifically but you know let's say
i'm this type of person a family member
calls me and their doctor says this i
could say
ah that doesn't sound right to me get a
second opinion i had that happen
recently some accountant gave me advice
and i was like that doesn't sound right
to me and i would ask them
questions and their answers didn't sound
right to me
so i got a second opinion and i was
right so
so again like you could learn you could
be the best physicist
on the planet without getting without
going through that path it's just that
you have a very
specific physical outcome that
in 98 of the cases not even 99 but 98 of
the cases
require the path but if you were going
to if you wanted to be
just learn all this physics you could do
a podcast you could write popular
science books you could work for a hedge
fund you could work for
a tech company like google or a
semiconductor company there's
many you can work for the cia and build
uh ways to track
people's cell phone gp you can work for
the irs actually
you know how the irs determines if
you're living in california or
versus texas because let's say you say
you're living in texas
because you want to avoid the state
taxes of california right it used to be
that
florida or florida right or florida
right it used to be the irs would say
let me see your utility bills
now what the irs does is they subpoena
your cell phone records
and using physics they make sure that
towers
uh all line up so that's 185 days a year
you were in
you were accessing towers in in florida
you know they
triangulate your phone and all this
stuff so
there's you could be a great physicist
without doing exactly what you're doing
right now
that's how i would choose to view my i
would view the truth so if i want like
let's say i'm i'm 52 years old
if i wanted to be a physicist right
right and so i would basically
read all the books study all the math re
you know and i've read you know
all the popular books like the michio
caico books brian greene stephen hawking
neil degrasse i've read all of those
books
at least the first chapter and the last
chapter that no no i know for sure
i read the whole book word for word and
uh but and then i'd have to like
study the next step would be like
feynman's courses on physics then i
would take some online courses and then
i'd
get into more textbook stuff but i could
do it i just can't do what you do
but then maybe i start a physics podcast
or maybe i
write to you and say oh here's some
ideas i have for your experiment
and you hire me to work on the
experiment so i'm not working for the
university i'm working for your grant
but i'm a physicist now doing physics
research and you trust it because
i would be giving you all the equations
and and you would say oh do you have
your phd and i would say
nah and you say okay i can't hire you at
ucsd but i'll hire you on my grant funds
and
blah blah blah so i could still be a
physicist i could choose myself to be a
physicist even now
yeah and be physics adjacent right um i
i i can even teach
i could do an online course at coursera
on physics if i write a popular physics
book
and then i could say look i don't have a
phd but i wrote the most popular physics
book of 2021
uh you know brian keating was the most
popular 2020 and
maybe i could teach at an online course
yeah online university we were number
one in lebanon as i told you a couple
weeks ago
yes um uh so yes i actually take that
taking that advice
and now i'm doing a tic toc course on
advanced uh general relativistic
quantum mechanics so that's a brilliant
idea by the way yeah exactly so yeah so
by the way that's
idea sex so so many people think oh
there's only one path
to be a tick-tock influencer which is i
gotta be
i gotta dance like a 13 year old girl um
or i've got a lip sync really well
but in fact weird things made a glass
and i and i do those and
and that freaks people out right yeah
yeah in fact actually you could be an
enormous
tick tock and by the way the eight the
average age of
people on tick tock it's going up every
single day so a
13 year old that audience has gone down
percentage of tick tock and the
uh 45 to 55 year old audience has gone
up so
so you could be this enormous famous
tick-tock
physics influencer and be doing legit
physics and explaining it
on tick-tock how much of that is his
first
is first mover advantage while i look up
your tick-tock account
how much of that is like well tick tock
is you you could be them you know neil
degrasse tyson of tick tock because he's
not on it and he's busy with twitter and
he has 13 million
followers on twitter but uh i'll never
get that um do you think that's first
mover advantage like tick-tock is viral
you're kind of leveraging the virality
sex of of physics and you know it's
first mover
it's a little bit first mover but but
not
you know is a combination of many things
it's a little bit first mover
it's a little bit which influencers like
you so that's kind of like a
like a lot the luck factor and then
there's just the quality of the content
that's just as important as
you don't have to be first movers the
quality of the content is probably the
most important
because at some point if you're
consistent with high quality content
some major influencer will bless you
with their hey check out
brian keating's page and then suddenly
you just get enormous numbers of of
users yeah because we've seen
i've seen famous you know comedians on
tick tock and they get nowhere
and then i see someone who just hits the
right zeitgeist and quickly they get a
million followers
yeah i mean uh you could easily double
my my tick tock following and by just
having one person join actually maybe
you'll join my tech talk dr brian
keating
oh i enjoyed it and you're james
altitude on tick tock
and uh jltitcher on twitter i want to
get in because it's not so often i get
to
uh pick the brains of somebody who's had
so many careers as you have
uh i wanted to co i want to go into
comedy right now
yourself some time james yeah of course
okay awesome uh so
before you were you you talked earlier
about your uh tedx
experience for my tedx i wanted to have
the experience of
bombing in front of a high maybe low
stakes but in a kind of high pressure
situation
uh before i went and failed potentially
on tedx i wasn't super nervous because i
give a lot of lectures it's my job right
but it's different it's a different set
of skills giving a lecture first of all
you're naked you're
without a podium you've got this time
limit this tick tock in your ear
like 15 minutes i was like what happens
at 15 minutes and my
speaking coach said they shoot these
blow darts at you uh you know
you're a nice coach i think my question
was not as nice
and then you know so i wanted to have
the experience of of being in a you know
in front of an audience
with that's hostile potentially or just
not exposed to me and not not positive
like
i'm not saying my students are positive
uh so i went to the comedy store here in
la jolla
and i did a tight uh tight uh 10
milliseconds now i did i did a tight two
minutes
uh i had a that's great to wha how did
you did you say to them hey i'm doing a
tedx san diego would you let me do
some time and they say uh all right two
minutes no no no it's
it's worse than that i didn't i didn't
say it at all and in fact i i just went
up there i had my wife there
and uh because i am uh you know i go to
an or
you know kind of uh links to be
associated with the with the jewish
community and i had a rabbi there and
and i was
like i can't curse and it's really hard
not to curse in front of like your rabbi
right so
so i did uh i wanted to do a clean set
and i was the last person at open mic
night
i had two minutes to go and i and i had
to be clean so i went up there
i tried a little shtick i went up there
with a tweed jacket with the suede elbow
and i took out a bubble pipe and i did
some jokes and
and you know and and they were all clean
and i was the last person i was the only
person who got a laugh and i want to
talk to you about that because it's kind
of like
uh and so so i should say um you are uh
owner or co-owner or a full owner of com
of stand up new york corner i don't know
about half of it
yeah and uh and i can't wait to check it
out uh next time i'm in new york city uh
later this year
and uh maybe do a set if you have an
open mic night but but the but the point
about comedy and
so i wanted to have this experience it
was a little difficult because everyone
there is drunk
and so i i made it i made a new rule
that you know all my students have to
have the two drink minimum before each
lecture
and things have gotten a lot better for
me and so we did this by the way
that's a joke yeah no i know actually
the pipe's not a joke that's a joke
yeah yeah i had a couple of jokes i had
one about uh a professor because i was
like i'm the i'm the you know
the stand-up cosmic it would be a joke
further
that's really just a premise it'd be a
joke further if like and then i was in
the middle of talking about the big bang
and and they uh one student started
heckling me and you'd have to
the actual punchline would have to be a
good heckle so yeah
that's right about that i want to get
into that because i want my private
philosophy that no
uh comedy is not victimless like there
has to be a victim sometimes it's you
sometimes the audience so that's the
heckler sometimes you're being heckled
but anyway
so i had some jokes i had like i'm
writing a book right now
uh called the timely history of briefs
instead of a brief history of time and
that flop but but i went through this
whole this whole bit about like this kid
who takes a class on ornithology
and have you ever heard this just stop
me if you've heard this joke as they say
uh but these kids taking taking my class
and when i was in college i was taking a
class in ornithology
and i wanted to learn all about it and i
learned about the birds and then the
final exam
all the professor was asking me was like
here's this bird track print on the
ground identify the bird
here's the bird print footprint on the
ground identified what the hell is this
this is such bs we're not learning
anything about their their migration
habits
their mating habits you know it wasn't
anything that we learned about the
stupid final exam so i went up
in the middle of class i handed in the
final exam i didn't put my name on it i
stormed out
professor reaches up and says wait a
second wait you didn't put your name on
it
and i said to the professor here figure
it out
and i put up my foot and it got a laugh
it was actually you know people people
laughed at that show
so there there's a case where so act
outs
that's called an act out yeah oh really
okay it has a name
yeah act outs are funny like if you ever
see like um
you know uh like a louis c.k
special he's often doing act outs like
he has the one
joke where he's teaching is a famous
joke he's teaching his daughter
uh monopoly but it's too hard for her
really it's like very emotional monopoly
and so he's acting like her voice and
then his voice and so that he's acting
out both roles
while he explains monopoly disorder and
act outs and voices are funny
so if you ever listen to jim gaffigan
part of his joke always is like he
has the voice he plays the voice of the
audience a little bit like
he's a joke again and like you know all
right
so is he gonna stop talking about horses
pockets yeah right yeah
so but but uh there's all these
different things so you didn't act out
which is funny and um but you know a big
common thing which which is like
you started to do with the physics class
example with the two drink minimum
is you can it's it's like an idea sex
you conflate two different areas
and oddly connect the dots so for
instance
um i saw someone the other day do a joke
um
where you ever notice that you know of
course
we care about women's equal rights ever
notice
the best food in the comes from country
beat women largely it's like no one ever
says
hey honey let's let's go out for
canadian tonight no you go out for
the middle east where they chop off
women's hands so
like so it's like you're conflating
these two concepts that are not really
connected
but there is this odd real connect the
dots
moment and now that's often the
construction of a
of a joke so like you were basically
turning your physics class
with the two-drink minimum into a comedy
club so i felt like that was kind of
going in the direction
of a joke yeah and um whereas the other
example the act out that's more of a
like a sketch type of joke
yeah like a bit a routine yeah and i
actually one of the things i mentioned
in this in the two minutes or whatever i
was like
um speaking of louis ck because and i
know you've had him on i know he's a
friend of yours uh but but i
like i haven't seen him on i haven't had
him okay i thought you did or you've
you've been in a room with him or
whatever anyway and someone's like oh i
have so much respect for him you know
that he writes
a new routine every year i'm like
you know what it's called if i only
write one new routine every year
it's called unemployment you know right
there's like i mean the standards for
and
he's funny i know he's controversial i'm
not i'm not but like that that was the
power like if i only come up with
one idea or one hour's worth of speeches
you know how many speeches i give or how
many podcasts you give
i mean uh it's it's it is very hard and
that's actually what i wanted to get
into
you know like the basis of comedy i
think is
uh you know and i kind of mentioned that
earlier like i got into like how do i
know i made an impact in someone's life
like it's kind of cruel to teach a kid
that there's four planets just to see
if they will remember what brian keating
said like you know i kind of mentioned
that and i said like you know the
dinosaurs were killed by you know
by they think it's killed by by by the
meteor falling but really
uh you know it's because their arms are
so freaking short they couldn't cover
their mouth and they sneeze and
whatever and i went through this whole
thing and again i'm like these people
just heard
a woman talking about her i'll just say
monthly cycle
and like with the most vulgar language
in the world and like this other guy
you know and it was like f-bomb f-bomb
f-bomb and like hi rabbi you know like
it was very challenging and i don't
think i'd ever want to do something with
with
a with a you know like i just feel like
that is demeaning to
like like that you have to use the app
like it loses its currency i mean i
think about
and most comics i would not all of them
maybe it's half and half i don't know
but most comics don't really you know
rely
on uh the curse words to
for for the the humor they might rely on
curse words for
timing like they need to throw in a word
as just like a beat
between the premise and the punch line
so and then you know what this
effing guy did like it just they needed
that extra two syllables or something
right um uh and also effing has the k
sound in it and that's yeah
allegedly right yeah like but seinfeld's
totally clean jim gaffigan gaff against
dolly clean yeah he before in front of
the pope but you know speaking of the
writing every uh
new routine every year the big argument
actually was seinfeld and louis ck
because seinfeld would not write a new
routine ever
and in fact i mean i think now he does
in his last special
but the last time i saw seinfeld before
him he actually did a joke i remember
him doing in 1992.
so you know but louis ck would never
have done that
um and and dave chappelle doesn't do
that so uh
you know i think most comedians now
rewrite quite a bit and certainly after
this
the weird thing about this pandemic and
lockdown is you kind of have to rewrite
every comedian now has to rewrite all
their material right none of the old
material
works like jerry seinfeld now has a
whole new routine
about going going out like you know
let's get ready to go out and then we're
going to go out where he makes fun of
the word out and then
and then he reverses and he's like okay
but when are we going back and like now
i gotta get back and now i gotta go back
to the car
and i think he but now that that joke
doesn't even make
contextual sense anymore in in even
after the lockdown
so so you know everybody's got to
rewrite their material now so
it's a little different story but yeah
that was a big shift in comedy when
it was clear louis c.k was was writing a
whole new set every year and dave
chappelle does like
three or four a year now yeah yeah i
mean it's it's it's non-stop
so i want to talk a little about the
physics of comedy and and really relate
that to
what we talked about earlier which is
this notion of entropy or surprise and
combinatorics so to speak
and you know i was thinking like why is
it so hard to make people
laugh uh and i think that and let me
know if you agree with it like
it's so easy to make people cry like the
difficulty gap between making somebody
cry like all i have to show you
is this mother who's about to give birth
or gave birth she had cancer and like
i'm starting to tear up right now like
it's so easy to make the world cry or
make them feel negative emotions well
think about if you listen to a song with
minor chords you're going to feel like
crying yeah and but but and
and i was relating that because like the
old joke is like how do you how do you
turn someone funny
uh into someone who's you know
completely unfunny and
it's not really a joke but but it's an
observation it's like ask them to
explain their jokes like
if you ever see like oh uh here's uh
what's his name jim carrey and he's on
the tonight
show or whatever and they're like why
are you so funny tell us why you're so
funny and that's like the least funny
he'll ever be
in their entire life like cause you
can't but like i don't have to explain
to you why it's sad if a mother dies
like right after she gives birth it's
like so it's like entropy there's more
ways to be
unhappy and unless i was thinking about
the second law of thermodynamics and
like
why is it that when you mix milk into
coffee you never see
like a spontaneous separation of coffee
and milk
because there's almost an infinite
number of combinatorics permutations
where milk and coffee are equally
blended but there's only one state
where there's half coffee half milk and
there's almost like an infinite number
of ways to be
sad and to be emotional but there's only
like really very precious few ways to be
funny
and like i don't think most comics are
that funny like i might not laugh i
agree with you
yeah so i mean i watch i watch as an
owner of a comedy club and a performer
i've watched
maybe a thousand different comedians
yeah most are just not
funny and and i think you know
like you said it's hard to there's so
many different like theories of comedy
like and there's so many different
um there's no one answer right like i
talked about
conflating two ideas you talked a little
bit about doing an act out
and then there's you know storytelling
uh
but but but yeah there's always an
element of surprise
like there's some tension that's created
and there's a pacing of that tension so
the tension lasts just
long enough but not too long that you
then release
the tension and uh
and you know then you can use these
other things like conflating to ideas
or doing an act out doing voices and um
but yeah there's no one theory of comedy
but maybe it's a good point that
you're putting energy into the tension
and the more there's a certain amount of
energy you put into that tension
so that when it's you know it's
potential energy and when it becomes
kinetic
that's when these yeah exactly and
that's what i was thinking like and i
wonder
i want to get your take on this too like
where is it hardest to be funny
when people expect you to be funny and
when is it and maybe this is because the
inherent tension in the situation
i don't know about you but like i've had
unfortunately like many you know how to
speak at a funeral
and and actually like they're more funny
funeral speakers you know
giving a eulogy than i think there are
comedians well that's actually so much
tension right
right that's also why like it's probably
funnier to get a laugh
at uh ted talk than in a comedy club
because i mean it's hard sorry it's
alright probably easier to get a laugh
at a ted talk that's comedy club
because you know or but let's take a
funeral
very specifically there's so much
tension already
you don't have to put as much energy in
like there's all this
tense energy anyway and no one's
released it
right the rabbi doesn't release it the
other
you know congregants don't release it uh
so if you release
if you give people an excuse to release
that energy just a little bit
like you open up the valve a little bit
it's it's an explosive laugh it's like
oh finally i've been holding in all this
potential energy i get to be kinetic for
a second and in a comedy club
first they're expecting just non-stop
kinetic energy
so you have to really like and there's
no tension it's like i'm out for a good
time and like
i'm expecting you like you let me down
if it'll be tense if you're not funny
jerk you know
right and i mean and that's a magic show
i expect to be fooled right
right um but still you expect to be
surprised like it's no good
if it's too easy for you to figure out
if if you know and then there's
um you know there's the the act and then
you think it's over but then there's the
other
surprise you know they always do at the
end but
so comedy and magic has have similar
features uh but more dexterity with with
magic
but um uh yeah i know with with comedy
it's all about
you can't and this was always my problem
like
when i when i first started out is that
i would try to tell a classic
joke but they knew it wasn't true i was
just telling like some dumb
joke that had a classic structure but
because they knew it wasn't true i
wasn't building
the tension but if i if i said you know
a joke like
um uh uh
you know something like oh i don't want
my daughter to go to college so i said
to her
like you know josie don't spend
don't spend you're a young pretty girl
don't spend
three hundred thousand dollars just to
have
sex non-stop for four years they should
be
paying you you that's the point and then
someone might be upset like you can't
i'm like oh i'm sorry she's a [ __ ] and
uh so like you could then
you know like you build up this tension
like is he really giving that advice
to his daughter and then you then you
there's all these different directions
you could go like i can act like i'm
clueless like oh no you're right i
should just say she's a [ __ ] or uh
or or i could or or i could say listen
i'm just being a good father
so like i'm um then and then i'm playing
the role of like a clueless
an unreliable narrator which i'm sort of
giving good advice
in a weird uh bizarro world but
uh i have this odd way of releasing the
tension of it
and so you know you do again it's a
matter of like
finding that right point of energy where
things are about to boil is everyone's
thinking like
this guy is the worst father in the
world and then i have to like break that
tension somehow
so they see that uh it's a joke
sort of they're still not even sure and
i cuz i could keep
diving into that and and you know then
um
you know maybe maybe my daughter can say
oh
uh you know climate change uh what do
you think of that and i'm like well what
you know what do you think of it and oh
you know molly she'll say to me
you know my teacher says your my
your grandchild my grandchildren are
going to be
dead by the time you know in the next 40
years like the world's going to
destroy be destroyed by climate and i
could say look
you know molly your grandchildren
i don't give a [ __ ] like right i don't
know the name of my great great
grandparents what the hell am i no i'm
never going to be yeah like i don't even
care about you that much
like why would i care about people i
don't have anything
yeah right i can see this is going to be
our father's day episode of the next day
so yeah well i have five kids so i have
non-stop material from
from my kids and uh and then you know
there's a lot of material being jewish
and depending on how you're raised and
and then there's a lot of material with
politics
and and so on so yeah anything that
brings up tension
and so for me and then by the way just
like a simple example this is like a
basic example with
coronavirus conflating two things i'm
not gonna get coronavirus i'm waiting
for coronavirus 2.0
because it'll have a better camera
better wi-fi you know
mulligan the coronavirus mulligan right
right like i'm conflating then how
versions of technology with this deadly
pandemic
right so can you imagine the netflix
netflix specials once we know about
coronavirus right so so like and then
but then i'm creating an intention like
how can he say he's not gonna get it
like does he not care does he think it's
not real
like you know they start getting angry
but then you you get into this
you connect the dots in this weird way
with the technology world
yeah yeah i i think the thing that
appeals to me so i kind of like
reverse hacked it because i found that
it made me better not not better for ted
you know for the ted talk but then when
i came back to being you know
my my professor job uh because that's a
situation that's that's tense
right because kids don't know if they
should laugh they maybe they don't want
to let you know i'll make up jokes is
stupid physics jokes
even if they're puns which you know i i
used to have it
you know an opinion that puns were like
the lowest form of humor but and i think
that's common but actually i think
a good pun you know is a pretty
beautiful thing like jim simon's
it's funny one of his meta skills is
clearly like his comedy and he told me a
joke
not on this podcast he's told me he's i
mean he was known
uh for being you know a jokester uh and
uh he told me once like
he was like going through this this bit
and i didn't realize he was telling a
joke
until like he just because he's like so
serious and you're in the room with this
guy's a billionaire right so there's
tension right it's building up he's like
you know it's really hard he's telling
me that's like you know i got
two houses and it's really you know it's
trouble enough just having one house and
once i needed to have over uh you know a
technician and
uh and and i thought to them you know i
said like well the plumber you know
you're gonna fix the house it's so
expensive like he came back he did the
he fixed the fix the house and he said
uh you know the the toilet's now working
and i'll be 300
and jim's like what the hell like i run
a hedge fund you know that's that's
three hundred dollars for
freaking a freaking toilet uh i don't
even charge that much you know
my fees and the plumber said yeah you
know i used to charge pretty low rates
when i was a hedge fund manager
like jim simon's like stand-up new york
i think so that's
so that's that's funny and um uh
i was trying i was thinking of one um
but anyway it's just again it's all just
a matter of like
that was a case where they're arguing so
there's some tension there in the story
and they just got a you know they
conflated the two occupations and
reversed it so there was a reversal
there's often a reversal
in in uh at the end of a joke it's like
completely the opposite of what you
think and then that's how that
that's how that surprise yeah manifests
the surprise exactly
so yeah but just thinking about it like
what what do you think
you know when i when i'm up there i
don't i'm not expected to be funny so
even something that's a corny pun or
i'll say
you know the unit of luminosity divided
by area is flux and i'll say like what
do you think the unit is what the flux
just whatever like stupid and like
they'll laugh and you know maybe they're
laughing because i'm gonna give them you
know control their entire destiny or not
but
uh but i wonder you know what about this
podium like
having a podium is a barrier and that's
part of the reason i felt like more
naked when i did the tedx talk
um like do you think it's it's kind of
taboo to use a podium or
like worst case scenario like using like
using note cards like adam carolla
who's a friend of a friend came to san
diego last november and we went and got
some and he was like working on bits and
he's like reading note cards he's like i
don't like this one
and i was like is that it just wasn't as
funny like he's a funny guy
no but he but he's doing that on purpose
no i know i know that but like i was
thinking like what if everybody used no
car like would we just accept it as
like that's just the way comedians work
just like wrapped use up yeah if
everybody used it it wouldn't work
because
they're specifically doing an experiment
the way a scientist would do an
experiment
they're they're um if they get even the
slightest reaction
even though their performance is
deliberately so poor
then they know that they can work on
that material because let's say and who
knows these percentages we're making
this up but let's say 50
of a joke's humor is the way you deliver
it on stage
and you know like if you had let's say
that
the joke that was the act out where you
showed the professor your
feet what if what if you said what if
you had just said look you're just gonna
have to look at my feet then
that wouldn't have been as funny you
needed the act out so
um you know like stephen wright is this
comedian known for his
very tight one-liners but he's also has
this very drawl
way so so if if he had just said very
excitedly and very fast like
uh it's a small world but i wouldn't
want to paint it it's not as funny and
for him uh he does it in this the
strollway right
small i lived at a i lived on a one-way
you know
dead-end street right like yeah like his
draw away
he creates his persona and the delivery
is is
that for him it might be well i don't
know the writing on that's hard but it's
at least 50 percent is the delivery
louis vk does so many act outs it's
half as the delivery dave chappelle is
huge on the delivery
all the comedians you see netflix
specials for it's huge on the delivery
uh that's such a big part of it and what
if i also
you have to be the weird thing too is
you have to be charming
like the audience has to like you so
um one comedian he'll go up on stage on
9 11
and you know he'll he'll just look at
the audience he'll stare at them
and he says it's 9 11 and you're in a
comedy club you
pieces of [ __ ] but he's so he makes it
come across as very charming in a weird
way
right so he's insulting them if he just
was like sort of an annoying
guy in his look or his presentation they
wouldn't laugh they would just hate him
and uh yeah so that's part of it as well
there's all these different components
that are part of it which is why
out of all the skills i've ever had to
learn you know i'm
you know i haven't had to be a a nobel
prize level
genius physicist but i'm a chess master
programmer
investor uh writer written a bunch of
books
uh you know all sorts of things yeah but
comedian is is the heart i mean i've
been doing this like
five six years and maybe more and um
you know from beginning to end i became
a top chess player i was new jersey's
you know when i was in high school i was
the junior champion of new jersey
did that in a year um but comedy is like
six years in
and i could see vast vistas
in the in the future of just things i
need to learn and then of course there's
the things i don't know
that i need to learn right the
dunning-krieger i mean i mean i've
toured with this guy
tony woods who's dave chappelle
acknowledged tony woods in the mark
twain awards as
tony woods was was dave chappelle's
mentor so tony and i
travel around together right before the
lockdown we did five different cities in
netherlands the netherlands
yeah and so i had i was able to see
first hand this is dave chappelle's
mentor and i just learned so much it was
incredible but it also shows just how
much there is to let go
yeah there is and there's so many
similarities between
you know even the profession that i have
it's it's not so dissimilar remember
most of my time
is not spent you know stroking my
non-existent beard pondering the
universe it's like how do i get this
truckload of concrete up the mountain
how do i get the funding agencies to
give us a
a covid gaap supplement you know how do
i convince
these other more brilliant scientists
that this is an idea with trial
so it's all these meta skills stack on
top of each other but i do find that you
know
we don't expect professors to be you
know stand-up comedians and
i'm not saying that you have to be you
know to to to be
successful but i think yeah there is a
chemistry there is uh
and it's not like manipulative chemistry
i think you know sometimes like a
magician will do something and you know
jerry seinfeld's you know famous lines
you know it's like what does a magician
do it's like looking here you're a jerk
here look at this
idiot you know like like that's
manipulative kind of charisma or
or you know presence in a way um but uh
but i wonder
you know kind of combining idea sex here
for a second you mentioned covid and we
talked about comedy
uh do you think that covid sorry do you
think that comedy would work
zoom let's say the zoom app you know
zoom uh stand up new york or sit down
new york
you know where you're on stage but
you're you know you're coming into the
audience and
on an app there's no audience it's not
like a netflix special
you're just like beaming like what do
you think about that idea well every
comedy club has been doing that this
person
oh really four months yeah so there's
something like a lot of uh zoom
comedy events i've been of course
invited to go on a whole bunch of them
i have not done it just because and i
haven't watched one
just because i actually don't really for
me i don't think would be fun i think
for me
is the visceral reaction of the audience
i really enjoy i mean i do instagram
lives
almost every day so i i try material but
even then you just see a bunch of hearts
come up and
uh or you see a smiley face it just
doesn't feel the same although i
enjoy being funny on those things but
it's not the same experience
and if i'm going to watch comedy there's
a big
advantage to being in person because you
then you get the energy of you
not only if you're performing but even
if you're in the audience you feel the
energy of the audience so someone's
really funny that's
like i watched louis ck for years uh
on youtube and i thought oh this guy's
funny but then the first time i saw him
perform in radio city music hall
i was laughing so hard i thought i was
gonna have to leave the room
yeah and uh it's just a difference like
in person it's just
much and again it's all related to
energy and it's related to likability
and
it's related to the tension in there and
everybody's tense around you all of a
sudden and then they're
burst out laughing at the same time and
so it's just
it's just different and then you know
also there's there's different
philosophies like dave chappelle's
philosophy and he's a very funny
comedian he's the best but
his philosophy is better to be
interesting than funny so his most
recent release
was not funny at all or it was like
three seconds of humor and there's
mostly he was talking about
you know george floyd events and so on
but uh uh
so but for him is is better to be
interesting than funny
then on the reverse side you have in
terms of the tension you have andy
kaufman
all he would do would be to increase the
tension
until it was unbearable and then he
would release he wouldn't tell jokes or
anything
right just was about the energy and
attention
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the university of california
san diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director